e
e e
okay so uh I've been
um I think what you what what you're
doing is very very
common um it's so common I've never seen
my way actually
done um so we have to start over like on
what we think is happening
okay um in
tenin this is going to represent ukia
spine their head's at the top here it
comes forward and usually what people
think
is that it's going to go like this in
some way so sometimes you have some ukas
that will slide
under okay and then sometimes you have
is like if this had a hinge here and
this top part goes like this they Bend
backwards okay at at the back and then
they go back they go backwards into the
back breakfall but either way uh if we
just look at the head
area uh it's going that way which in our
Dojo is east and then the head is
brought West okay in either way whether
the feet keep going
or whether it bends
here and then they do the step back back
break fall or some do a a a rear
somersault or a rear uh uh forward roll
or sorry rear roll whatever none of that
stuff is what we want to do because
they're coming from west to east and we
pushing that head back from east to west
so that's a y y Clash okay we don't want
to do that so if uh this is where the
heaven arm would be what we want to do
instead is we know for the head to
go
from back to West then it has to be
brought on that Circle the kagaya circle
so that it's forward inertia is
maintained you you have to do that in
every technique any technique where
there's a back breakfall there's this
little yield here um I've come to this
is a y yield but I've come to actually
uh uh sometimes refer to it as o Sensei
y yield because this is what he does all
the time okay and none of none of the
people do it that came after him okay
but the head comes forward it's going to
keep going with his forward iner on this
Loop sometimes I refer to it as it's
like KES on the head like a lot of
people will do it on kesi but they don't
do it on any of the other throws teni
nugget Ed nugget K but it's the same you
do it the same way so think of it that
way the head is going to go forward on
this Loop like this
okay um and then what happens is uh now
I'm not fighting it because now it's
inertia is going
uh West even though the body's coming
east okay and now what I have to do is
help make the feet light okay and the
way you do that is you now bring the
head this
way okay your hip's going to go in
here crap all right you're going to go
this way you make that little Loop and
now you come this way
then your hip goes in here and this part
starts to now folk them around this way
and as the feet are
lifting the head is getting light so the
head we know is going down but I'm not
actually throwing it down it's more I
pick the feet up and I help pick the
feet up by moving the head this way and
then eventually that head Falls over on
this side okay so let's fil it from over
here so you can see more of the angles
the head is going forward it's going to
do that
kotes on the head now the forward
inertia is going rearward okay then I
got to get weight off the feet and so I
bring the head this way with my hip over
here the head goes this way the feet go
that way and the feet start to lower the
head and the guy falls down okay
okay one more time this way on the head
then back this way Hip is over here
it'll lighten the feet the feet will
come around as I keep guiding the head
around my body and the guy falls down
okay not doing
this like that
okay so let's look at some of the more
common ways that
people um um mistakenly end up Yong Yong
clashing that means that they're coming
this way and you just took energy uh in
100 uh 180° opposition to them okay so
we'll do that
now okay uh let's go over
here so probably the most common way is
we'll just look at the Earth hand is the
earth hand the person's coming in and
then we pull it this way
okay so this hand looks like
this
okay uh a lot of people are thinking
that you're going to shove that down
like that and then you have now shikaku
and then you enter into
it but what happens is is when you when
you pull this thing around like that
you can see the pull I'm doing on his
shoulder so I'm just demonstrating it
from this angle
okay
okay and so now that
shoulder is coming back which means that
other shoulders coming forward and you
can see how it sets them up for that
turn that you have uh that problem with
okay which means if he wants to he could
take that
turn you
see and that's that's the problem so I'm
contesting on the grip and now I made it
possible for the UK who wants to turn to
turn
okay it goes this
way and it doesn't matter if I
enter and to do it every time okay so
what we want to do on this hand is not
go this
way it's going to help with that pattern
so I showed the pattern on this side so
we'll do it on this side okay he's going
to go
in and then around me this way
okay so if we look at certain things
one when I do this hand
and I go here like that we want to look
at where his foot is to my hip it's way
over
there and we want to bring him more in
past my hip and that's where that hand
drops I want him past my head
and that's where this leg comes in now
this now brings his head this
way this way not this
way let him pass you and then you enter
when you cut this arm down don't pull it
you just guiding it is very light here
that's how you know when to drop it when
you don't feel his energy on it anymore
boom that's when it drops and that's
when your body comes
in this way
drops
in this foot is your my foot so you
decide where it goes to allow all that
to happen you kind go
forward but he has to pass you before
the hand drops you can go back he has to
pass you before the hand drops okay
let's just work on the earth hammer
okay so this
is more of my intermediate student and
she has that 180° oppositional mindset
you can
see where things
are okay it's very very
common try it again
she's just running at him
okay so uh pay attention to the grid we
have here so
north south camera West East okay and so
as I'm doing this I'm not going to go
here in
West you're already starting that
Circle he's not going east any more okay
and so and when I enter I'm more
entering North if you pay
attention so I'm not going
here
here do it again this is
oppositional I'm going to change his
direction right away and now we're
Circle
here oppositional
everyone thinks that's going to work
okay instead
Circle Bo this
way Circle this
one if you watch my feet the deeper he
gets my uh EDI foot
probably moves away from the direction
he came from so right now it's on this
[Music]
line he's going in
yeah I'm going that way okay so one more
time right
here going this
way Circle
Circle
[Music]
Line start this
rotating okay other thing that this does
for you versus this is it allows his
Center to kind of stay there and that's
what allows him to turn on it
this is going to bring his Center up and
this now has some resistance to the turn
cuz his inertia is going this way he's
hard to turn there he needs to keep his
Center over his foot now he can pouette
on that
foot it's hard to pouette like
this it's a lot harder
okay so combine those get the center up
a lot of times your UK have their butt
back you see you're making their butt go
back as you're doing this they end up
grouo marks walking around you and when
you take their weight off that's when
they can turn on you so how that Center
up in circle
hey back on the circle try it now we'll
we'll look at the at the um Heaven hand
okay so I'm not just getting out of the
way
again I'm not doing this so my my hand
if you watch the heaven hand a lot of
people the second mistake that people do
is the heaven hand is going forward
forward cuz they're going to throw that
anytime my hand is going
forward and I'm oppositional to him
forward I don't want that just like this
hand is going this way this hand is
going this way too it's coming back
towards me back towards me
okay so a lot of times just like on the
earth hand uh people bring it only a
little bit where his foot SN over here
and then they start bringing it back
here the same thing you get sub opening
but now it's going it's going that way
and it stops a person stops a person and
when it stops a person it gives him a
choice to turn on it and you can do the
forward
R what we're trying to do is stop him
from being able to turn by preoccupying
his Center with the forward
inertia it's hard to turn when your
Center is being pulled that way okay
that's that's our our counter to the
turn all right so we work on this
hand and it's the IM spiral yes but it
wants to control the
elbow and this becomes as if I'm holding
here and I pull this forward
here and I'm pulling it forward so he
keeps going
forward when you combine this elbow like
that and they're both pulling it's not
possible to turn cuz there's pulling
here try to turn it's pulling him that
way so we're going to just look at this
hand and this hand goes here and it
moves him back for
forward and back this way that's what I
mean it's making him go
forward and it brings him to here I
don't bring this to here I bring his
head to here to me
don't go to him cuz then the hand has to
go forward so let's say you're here and
you're like I can't go anymore it goes
up and that brings him
in it's not I don't want you to do it
with your turn with your turn I don't I
don't really change the relationship
we're just oriented
differ is they you're here like I can't
get anymore that's where you start going
up it brings him
in okay try that part of the heaven hat
okay all right so I combine the two
hands I combine the
footwork and with those that's my in
yield okay so I'm going to show
it I'm going to bring him to the heaven
hand here okay once he's there to go
forward is now
to contest him and when you go forward
that's where he can turn
so what I'm going to do instead is move
out this way and that's that's the K on
the head so I was showing it on the
sword on this side so I'll show it here
I bring him into the hand once he's
touching this hand is going like
this that's what moves him this
way and that's what I'm calling ense Yin
y
this
way so if you pay
attention is if he was to pouette on
this
foot he has to leave it in place you
see but when you do this yield watch
that
foot C if he tries to turn on it it's
getting
moved the throw I I haven't thrown yet
but there's already enough
reconciled West East direction that he's
already falling that way okay without
me moving my hands from where he came
from okay try that for okayy a second
detail on this on the heaven hand okay
for him to
turn he can't have his head going the
other way so
here would be a a a linear energy
against his chin and he's going to turn
this way the head the head is now acting
against that okay so when he's in the
heaven hand and he she like that and you
C you're throwing him basically into the
hand so he's pressing into the hand okay
it's not it's not easy to turn your head
that way because even though I'm
bringing his head this way if if you
don't
mind his linear inertia is pushing him
into my hand you see and as I move this
way it's difficult for him to turn his
chin in the direction do do you
understand that
whereas if I don't have him cuz I'm
pushing my hand this way his forward
inertia he's going to yield to it by
turning and he's in the pivot okay so
I'm going to smash him into my arm boom
and it makes it hard for him to turn the
chin and I don't need him to not turn
the chin ever I just need him not to
turn the chin long enough for me to
enter
okay when I
enter and I have him
here I don't now try to throw his
head okay I have him like this so go
back where I show you where I'm at
everything elbows bringing it in on the
heaven hand uh Earth hands bringing his
Center forward I make a make contact
there i y yield here okay and now to
throw my
arm is to still contast what I'm going
to do
instead is as the weight is not on his
legs now and the inertia was coming
through on his
Center imagine here's his head I hold
his head
still camera over here you're going to
grab his Center this camera over here
this is what I'm working with this makes
his feet light and I can now make his
head light okay so when he gets to where
I want here this is where I'm coming in
and hitting this
base as the base gets displaced his head
gets lighter and all I'm doing is
guiding it around me I'm not throwing
them down so I don't ever have to make
my arm go against that energy coming
west to east just around
sh
okay so uh what I'm doing here is that
body lock concept we have a video on the
body lock maybe more than one but it's
the only way I throw I only throw with
the body lock especially on the back
breakfall um as opposed to requiring a
hinge in the middle of his body like the
bonai does or uh the Federation at large
where they sit their butt down you see
that it has that hinge in the body still
is just going the other way than bonai
and uh none of that happens martially uh
people that are aggressing uh they will
lock their own body up uh and then with
inertia too the inertia acting on him
will lock the body up so all I have here
at this point with all that stuff I've
done with the tabaki the ashaki the yin
yield the I adhesion Etc is to create a
kind of rigidity on his body that's what
you want okay um you don't want you
don't want this
okay and what I'm doing here is and I'll
just go see the video on the body lock
okay but there is the ademi angle where
I can be on the front top part of it
like the bul in and the bottom part back
of it and that's what you're throwing
when you do these techniques it's kind
of I'm gaming it here but instead of
bending them backwards and then he
go you're kind of just hitting
here you want it to lock but your body
has to be in a certain place for that
okay and that I found even my dish you
don't quite get it as you go down in the
rank there's a place what they usually
Miss is the coordination between the
upper part and the bottom part uh and
then secondarily where where does this
EDI go they missed that part they're
doing some other stuff over here over
this way like a trip let me move your
leg P like this and that's not it you're
coming in one is here this is
exaggeration just so you can see the
physics involved okay cuz remember in
the technique we're going to figure a it
on the vertical plane here I'm not doing
that this has to coordinate with this Ed
displacement
so that his body can lock okay that's
the body lock and that's in the
technique that also makes it very very
difficult to turn okay try it